these have been described as the most
expensive rocks in the world until
NASA's Apollo moon missions they'd laid
on the lunar surface for millions of
years undisturbed by humans from 1969 to
1972 there were six Apollo missions
which returned to Earth with samples it
was hoped they'd uncover secrets about
the moon they ended up teaching
scientists a lot about the earth to
[Music]
nine containers of lunar samples were
brought back to earth scientists
studying the rocks learnt a great deal
about the many impacts early in the
moon's development these created huge
craters some the size of large countries
ancient volcanic eruptions then filled
some of these basins with vast plains of
lava creating the dry seas that can be
seen by humans on earth billions of
years later but the moon rocks also
revealed the biggest impact was the one
that created the moon itself scientists
found the moon rocks to be surprisingly
perhaps disappointingly
like those on earth it turns out that
the earth and the moon are chemically
very similar indeed as if twins it was
this revelation that led to a
game-changing idea the giant impact
theory the latest version of this theory
involves the new idea of a Celestia in
this theory the impact fills nearby
space with a doughnut of hot vapor both
the Moon and Earth are formed from the
magma rain that resulted the
gravitational pull which binds the moon
and earth to each other became the main
cause of the rise and fall of the
Earth's ocean tides scientists believe
these tides could have been crucial for
the evolution of animal life on Earth by
offering a route from under the sea to
above it for almost 50 years no human
has returned to the moon now missions
are being planned to its unexplored
territories just as the United States
was the first nation to reach the moon
in the 20th century so too will be we be
the first nation to return astronauts to
the moon in the 21st century the hope of
the next generation of scientists is
that by studying new samples of rock
they can unlock many more of the new
secrets and even some of the Earth's